renewed fighting between the drc army
and the m23 movement and rwanda is
accused of backing the rebels
what's behind this round of conflict and
could it escalate into a full-blown war
between the two neighbors
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom more than 25 years
after the first congo war the democratic
republic of congo and rwanda are once
again engaged in dispute the central
african neighbors have accused each
other of firing rockets across their
shared border including a strike that
killed two congolese children
this seems to have been triggered by
fighting between the m23 rebel group and
state forces in the east both congo and
the united nations have accused rwanda
of supporting the m23 movement the u.n
has urged all parties to immediately
cease all forms of violence
the region doesn't need a new crisis
let's keep the channels of dialogue open
at all levels including at the community
level and help preserve the progress
achieved in the recent years thanks to
the various cooperation mechanisms
the march 23 movement or m23 is also
known as the congolese revolutionary
army
it's a rebel military group based in
eastern areas of the democratic republic
of the congo mainly in the province of
north kivu its leadership is made up of
members of the tutsi ethnic group they
say their aim is to fight enemy groups
founded by hutus who fled rwanda after
the 1994 genocide
the rebels merged with the congolese
army under a peace deal signed on march
23 2009
but in 2012 they said the deal had not
been upheld and broke away naming their
group the march 23rd movement
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in akra kambale musavoli is a
researcher at the center for research on
the congo kinshasa
in kigali
niringabo rohumuliza is a political
commentator
in tilburg the netherlands felix
nidahinda is a researcher focusing on
conflict peace and justice in the great
lakes region a warm welcome to you all
and thank you so much for joining us
today on inside story kambale let me
start with you today what's behind this
new round of violence it's hard to tell
i was beyond that for almost six months
now there have been an uprising of the
m23 uh in the east but they're not the
only militia group
active in the east so it's very hard to
know we do know that there have been
peace negotiations taking place in
nairobi with the many militia groups in
the drc
to come up with some resolution for
peace and stability
further is something organized by the
president of kenya and during this
period for some strange reasons
the m23 has started their campaign to
attack
u.n peacekeepers and also the congolese
forces in specific areas
and that has continued and we've noticed
that the military military power has
increased tremendously by having power
to attack at night
by having weapons they didn't have
before which has caused the congolese
government to state that there is tacit
support
of our congress neighbors are
particularly around that to the m23 so
as
i can say i can say no one really know
why the attacks has taken place at this
present time but it is a destabilizing
force at the moment kimball if i could
just follow up with you you mentioned
that there are talks or negotiations
going on between different groups right
now first of all how many groups are we
talking about and secondly
any indications on how those talks are
going i mean in terms of the militia
groups
some numbers take it up to a hundred uh
militia group there but you have to
understand even what that actually means
a group may have 20
rebels in its force are comparing the
territory and they'll call themselves a
rebel group but the way to look at the
groups in the eastern part of congo is
that you have
groups that are supported by congo's
neighbors particularly random and uganda
and you do i have a
local uh rebels who are either
protecting the territory of uh
interacting into
illicit trade of minerals but the
essence of that is that since 1996 uh
congo has not known peace stability uh
mainly because of the interference of
its neighbors running in uganda who
continued uh explicitly to support rebel
groups
in the east coast of the civilization of
the congo yes i can say it's about a
hundred of them but it doesn't mean much
but why are they negotiating um no
congress just joined
the east africa community uh there
seemed to be
uh a political will in the part of kenya
to see how congo can be stabilized uh
maybe to bring about the potential of
the congo for the east african community
and um
as i said you know
in nairobi they've been really really
pushing hard to have business stability
and the negotiation has been for uh
rubber groups to put down their arms
either be integrated in the society or
in the military and he hasn't concluded
and it's still ongoing at the moment uh
gatete i want to ask you about um
how you see things from your vantage
point there uh in kigali why are
tensions escalating now so from kigali
people are surprised and confused
by two things two developments the first
development was as soon as m23
re-emerged to attack the drc m23
uh the you know the military wing has
been in rwanda for for
just under 10 years you know the the the
political wing has been grounded just
for just under 10 years but the military
wing has been in uganda for five years
and five years late five years later
they crossed and camped into the dic
forests without being attacked and
without attacking anyone so everybody
was aware of the existence of m23 in
congolese forest for at least the last
five years
now when they started attacks recently
ronda was surprised that the dlc the
first thing the drc did was to
point fingers at rwanda and say if they
attacked they
um
they would that means they must be they
must be supported by rwanda i think that
one of the problems and the the reason
this empanada exists is that congolese
often do not make a difference between
people who speak in rwanda in drc and
random citizens so
and this m23 one of the things that they
are demanding i understand is the fact
that they're discriminated in their
country and they are considered to be
rondons even though they are fully
congress
so every time they attack and because
they attack speaking in a rwanda they
look like london people conclude that
rwanda is behind them and so that in
itself the accusations
were followed by
measures we had the an airline around
the air that was flying into drc that
was whose license was suspended
uh
the ambassador was summoned to be
to receive letters of protest and so on
that was fine in itself
uh it wasn't great but it was already
it was it was okay
that because uh you know friendship is
something you first start when it works
works it doesn't make it work but
the problem is that
following these fightings
now the dlc has been
shelling rwandan territory and
territories of kiniki
which is the close to the border with
drc and giselle
now if you look at the morphology of the
rwandan
country which is a very small country
densely populated
a bomb that falls on the random
territory has
much more devastating effects
than you know than fightings that have
been going in congo for 20 years which
have no effect in kinshasa or just 200
kilometers from from the where the the
war is happening so ronda is not like
congo runner is extremely vulnerable to
any of the you know of the
accidental or otherwise deliberate
shelling on its population kenya is
i'm sorry i'm sorry to interrupt you let
me get back to that point you're making
in just a couple of minutes uh felix i
want to ask you about your opinion on on
if all this tension that is escalating
right now could actually spill over into
a full-blown war between the neighbors
and and how big a fear is there right
now of escalation and and what would
that mean for the region
at least my reading of the situation is
that
there are serious fears that this can
escalate into a regional world uh given
the nature of for example the
the accusations that are going
from different sides and giving the the
dynamics the narratives and especially
also the the the kind of the flames that
are igniting the media particularly
social media
uh
and of course politicians reacting also
towards all of that
uh i think that the threat is realistic
i mean we know now with the fighting in
guna ghana with the border posts
uh occupied by the m23
anything can happen from there and with
of course
my understanding now from what i can
read on social media are subject to
verifications uh a lot of congolese
soldiers having crossed again some with
all needed caveats into uganda a lot can
happen
but
and one would really hope that
all
actors of goodwill from the regional
powers like kenya and so on and
international intervenors probably need
to do something to avoid that escalation
rather than that it looks like we are
quite in a dangerous territory
the african union has launched efforts
to try and mediate this crisis between
kinshasa and kigali have has any
progress been made
well no not really unfortunately no
progress has been made
because uh the negotiations have to be
based on facts and evidence and we have
what we call an extended joint
verification mechanism that is based in
drc
whose reports
the dlc does not believe i mean for
example the dlc is adamant that rwanda
is supporting m23 in spite of any
independently verifiable facts
they use you know they they extrapolate
they say if they are efficient and if
m23 is efficient on a battlefield that
means they're supported by rwanda but
the joint verification mechanism has not
established that so negotiations cannot
go on because the drc for instance would
say that m23 comes from rwanda uganda
would confirm that m23 actually comes
from uganda but it but the dic would
persist that it comes from rwanda even
though there's no evidence to that
there's the the internal political
dynamics of the drc that makes it easy
to point fingers at rwanda which have
nothing to do with rwanda it's congolese
internal affairs which then makes it
difficult for the congolese government
to do honest and open negotiations
because they have to please their own
internal political pressures
so
i mean if you're saying that there is a
mechanism but it sounds to me like
you're also saying that that mechanism
really can't function uh
in an appropriate way right now i mean
first of all let me ask you what are
rwanda's immediate concerns and and how
then can things actually start being
de-escalated so the mechanism actually
con
functions very well under the patented
of the international
commission for the great lakes region we
have mechanisms that include more than
10 countries they function they do
provide reports on a frequent basis in
fact what they are saying right now is
that yes the drc is sharing bonds on the
random territory none of these
international
independent mechanisms are saying that
ronda is supporting drc which is why
there's no country in the world that is
condemning rwanda for supporting m23
because simply because there's no
evidence of such
such allegations only diaz is making the
allegations now how can the situation be
the escalated
one
it can be escalated if the drc is
capable of
dealing with internal problems by
negotiating with his own
uh several groups that in my opinion
they have not been able to defeat
militarily but that's an internal drc
issue number two we are worried about
two things as random citizens one they
bomb london territory
when you bomb kiniki you are bombing
home to mountain gorillas this is
critical to us because tourism we
present 30 percent of our national
income when you bomb israel you are
bombing a very densely populated region
with the strong population
this is very dangerous for us we cannot
that's number two number three and the
last point that worries us very much
now
the the government the army of the drc
having lost
repeatedly on the battlefield against
intelligence have recruited fdlr which
is the first day of liberation of wonder
former people who committed the genocide
who lived in the dnc now they are
collaborating
with the national army of the drc and
the communist president admitted it
now the two are being supported by the
monument which is the u.n force now
imagine a human force that is
collaborating with genocide perpetrators
on a daily basis fdlr is becoming
mainstream and this is something that
worries
london's side so negotiation
um kambale uh you heard gate there uh
bring up the role that the u.n is
playing and i want to ask you about that
i mean the u.n is now urging all parties
involved in the growing tensions between
kashasa and kagali to immediately cease
all forms of violence in these border
regions between rwanda and drc um
from your perspective are there
immediate steps that can be taken to
ease the tensions and is the u.n in any
way effective in all this
well first we have to make a correction
there have been countries and mutual
institutions that have
actually uh put pressure on ronda to
stop supporting uh rebel and interfering
even the last statement coming from
the secretary general the spokesperson
uh clearly stated uh indirectly stated
that outside forces a neighboring
country should stop supporting uh the
m23 uh it may not be explicitly saying
run that but we know what he refers to
when he says outside so many nations has
done so
specific for the united nations the
united nations depends the united
nations peacekeeping forces they depend
on the u.n security council uh
particularly the political will of the
council to end the crisis in the congo
and for the past 25 years
we have seen numerous times
that the political will has lacked um
one will ask why you know i always put
it very clearly
there are two nations in the security
council who are playing cover for rwanda
specifically the united states and the
united kingdom i mean some of you may
know
that rwanda is about to receive over 150
million dollars uh for receiving
refugees from the uk so the uk has
everything to do with making sure that
its ally on the african continent does
not is not held into account same for
the united states but concretely
what we bring about peace in congo i
think uh we must be very genuine even
honest when we are having this
discussion about drc because we're
speaking about it as the m23 is a
reliable force that's just appear but
it's been going on for 25 years when
you're talking about the m23 it's
connected to the cndp
when you're talking about the cndp it's
connected to the rcd
while you are talking to the rcd is
connected to the afdl so i've just threw
some acronyms there what are these names
those are the same rebel group that
exists in the congress since 1996 how do
i know that the leader of the so-called
m-23 sutanima kanga who has
a arrest warrant from the congolese
government who is not bothered he
travels
in uganda all the time there are also
m23 uh rebels with arrest warrants who
are living in iran and they have not
been extradited to the drc they are all
have been implicated in the wars in the
congo that has taken the lives of
millions and even lately the person who
spoke before me
i mentioned there was a shelling of uh
giseni and uh kinige
taganda was
was at the icc
he failed to say
that just yesterday there was a bombing
of a school in the drc by the london
military the shell de bomb
a school
where a six-year-old and a
seven-year-old has died so for peace and
stability to take uh to
come into the region we must be honest
why do we have conflict it's very simple
it's the destabilization of the drc to
get control of congo's wealth
using proxy rubber militias
in this case we are discussing the m23
felix um you know you heard cambale
there talk about destabilization so i i
want to ask you
i mean
is the international community doing
enough to try to put pressure uh when it
comes to this situation and and are we
going to see the international community
step in to help de-escalate things
i mean
i can always hope and probably think
that there will be some kind of
background channels and uh and a lot of
jokes and a lot of uh
let's say diplomatic kind of activity
around trying to to find a solution at
least at the interstate level
and then even at the regional level i
mean kenya has been very much present in
the last year i would expect countries
like tanzania and
and uh and so on to be to be
very much involved in trying to find a
solution that being said
i guess we never have that
final let's say lasting solution unless
we really try to look at the depth of
what are the issues are uh
my friend here kabalye already just
talked about the you know the acronyms
and backgrounds to the different
movements
but we need to look at the phenomenon of
mm-23 as part of the bigger kind of
problem with eastern diases and security
and pieces
in eastern drc and the incidents on the
on the wider region
and we have to look at the history and
the the tone of unresolved issues and
these need to be broken down at
different levels as well there are
issues which are at the very local level
in north kivu
specifically and in south hebrew
specifically for example now we are
talking about m23 but last year we had
close enough to the same level of heat
and debate about the whole platform of
south kivu with
with fighting still very much of going
there so
in south cave as well we have quite a
lot of local unresolved issues and these
tend to have quite a big resonance at
the national level against strictly
speaking within the congolese
landscape and here we are talking about
issues of identity ethnicity citizenship
control of land and
issues of power including representation
within power including at the local
level traditional authorities and so on
part of the legacy of the belgian
colonial systems inherited already in
the congo which successive post-colonial
administration have never really lived
up to reckoning with
or at least
organized as should be in order to
reflect modernity
second
we need to look at the indeed at the
regional level so
local
national but also regional avenues there
are many of those problems for example
when you're talking about the the
identity issues when you read
most of the narratives you have now
around m23 on social media lists if
you're only to stick to that space m23
doesn't exist it's nothing but a cover
for rwanda in fact there is no such a
thing as a random phone everything about
m23 is ronda and i think that is a very
dangerous accuracy to take
there are issues maybe that need to be
investigated around where m23 how does
it thrive is it supported or not
i think that's the work for all of those
verification mechanisms i'm sure that in
the coming
months and years we'll get you in
reports on that we have this wrong felix
if i could i'm sorry to interrupt but if
i could if i could follow up with you
about a point that you're making there i
mean you have a situation here where
both drc and rwanda are accusing each
other of supporting armed groups and and
even of launching cross-border attacks
um
you know we come back to this to this
question of are there actual mechanisms
that exist
that are able to investigate these
claims and and how are the facts
established
we have i mean for many years now we
have had a u.n
group of experts on on the drc that is
meant always to investigate what happens
in that part of the country every time
uh
he has
produced tons of reports and so on on
what goes on
but
i mean
documenting is one thing
coming with actions that are meant to
resolve problems that are identified is
another thing and most of the time
action lacks when it comes to
resolving
in a lasting way some of the issues that
are identified at the different levels i
was talking about i keep insisting there
are local issues there are domestic
issues in the dlc there are
regional issues and international didn't
come to talk about so international when
you talk about for example minerals and
so on i'm sure that there are regional
interests in
in commercial interests between the drc
andre and the neighbors but also there
are international probably even more
impactful international links so all of
those
need to be tackled and if you tackle one
of those and you don't address the
others you can only postpone the problem
but you'll always be there i would admit
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests kambale musavuli katete
niringabo melisa and felix indahinda
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim zhum the whole team here in
doha bye for now
[Music]